como si la colina se rompiera en pedazos
en pocas horas el lodo se adentró
cientos de metros en el mar Arrasando
todo a su paso Los buzos estuvieron
peinando las aguas de la costa italiana
de isquia con la ayuda de helicópteros
aquí es donde se encontró la primera
víctima una mujer de 31 años que
trabajaba en una tienda local hallada
muerta a cientos de metros de su casa
los bomberos están turnando para buscar
en la zona tratando de encontrar a los
desaparecidos pero la tarea sigue siendo
difícil en paralelo el gobierno decretó
el estado de emergencia lo que hace que
sea complejo es que nos encontramos bajo
la zona debilitada por el
desprendimiento las casas están llenas
de barro por lo que es muy complicado
Acceder al interior y continuar nuestra
búsqueda
alrededor de 200 personas fueron
desalojadas algunas se refugiaron en
este hotel cerca del puerto esta mujer
refugiada con su hijo y su nieta se
enteró de que su cuñada fue encontrada
muerta bajo los escombros
estamos tristes mantuve la esperanza
hasta el final otra tragedia en esta
ciudad y en esta familia no sé cómo voy
a afrontar los próximos días
[Música]
esta familia Tuvo más suerte su casa
sigue en pie a pocos metros de la
trayectoria de la luz
ves nuestra casa aquí pasó por allí y es
que ya recibió casi 13 centímetros de
lluvia en 6 horas la mayor precipitación
en 20 años Este alud es el tercer
desastre natural que golpea la isla ya
víctima de un terremoto en 2017 y de
mortales inundaciones en 2019